a school in Fort Lauderdale Florida is
in a bunch of hot water after a teacher
reportedly banned one of her students
from reading the Bible during free
reading time she actually called the
parents phone at home and left a message
and we've got this brings up a lot of
interesting things obviously about
freedom of religion and this was free
reading time at the school which implies
that the kids can read anything that
they want to read now I know you guys
aren't huge on religion so I thought
this would be an interesting topic for
you guys to handle what do you make of
them
this teacher it wasn't a school-wide
thing apparently but this teacher felt
that this kid could not read the Bible
in class is that okay no I don't think
that's okay I mean I'm normally very
against having religion in schools but
that's having the school push religion
on the kids in this case the kid just
was an individual who wanted to bring
the book to school and read it and
that's a personal choice and I don't
think that that should be handled the
way that they did you know a personal
choice well I mean yeah the First
Amendment protects my right to not read
the Bible the same way it protects this
child's right to read the Bible this is
a blatant violation of the Constitution
and there's a you know there's action
being taken now there are lawyers that
are working with the with the students
family and this could potentially be
pushed up through the court system so I
I'm not sure if this teacher is aware of
the fact that she's violating the
Constitution by telling this child that
he can't read
this book in her classroom and maybe
that'll be corrected as soon as she kind
of reads the Constitution like that kid
reading the Bible is gonna influence the
other kids around them you know it's not
being forced on anybody it influenced
the other kids around him it doesn't
matter because the truth is that is a
that our like the law of the land
protects so this wasn't something that
was like you said part of the curriculum
this isn't something the teacher was
pushing on to the students but yes you
have every right to read whatever
religious text you want to read in a
public place in a private place whatever
it be one thing if he was reading this
book when he was supposed to be reading
Tom Sawyer and making a big stink about
it but in free reading class to tell a
student that he has to take his Bible
out of the classroom his Quran out of
the classroom his Torah out of the
classroom whatever is yeah it's a
violation of the First Amendment yeah I
feel like carrying around a Koran retort
that I feel like it's a big huge thing I
used to seeing it kind of in these in
these there are giant Bibles to I'm
ready
they're like an ark and you have that
like five people pushing his Bibles are
much yeah oh there's the million of
those like stupid Bible app all right
you're right it's not about the sizing
book should we be a little afraid of so
we're blaming this on the teacher not
the the school itself so that that's one
thing but should we be a little afraid
of these people that are pushing the
anti religion thing even if you're not
for religion in the public sphere that
they're pushing it to this extent like
well that she called and she said you
know this isn't gonna happen in my class
that there's there's a danger really in
her methodology of how she's trying to
preach liberalism or something
absolutely I mean there's as much of a
danger there as there is pushing
religion on kids you don't want to make
up their mind for them it should be up
to the child as we were saying before
yeah so yeah I mean I don't know if a
child can really make those kinds of
decisions I mean that's another that's
another debate entirely but aside from
that I I think we need more context like
is she preaching anti religion or she so
afraid of First Amendment violations and
afraid of all the things that she's seen
in the news lately that she thought that
this was the right course of action like
oh no I don't want to Bible in my
classroom because I could get in trouble
for that
maybe like that's the thing is that when
you become very extreme on one side or
the other of the issue I think and
because it's such a polarized issue it's
such a political kind of hot-button
issue I think that there's confusion
surrounding it and this again we don't
we don't have context it could be that
this woman was trying to push a specific
agenda it could be that she was afraid
of the opposite agenda being you know
seeming like it's being pushed in her
classroom so I think with a little more
context we would understand this a
little better but until then it's kind
of hard to tell yeah where do you guys
fall in terms of where the where the
debate should be on this because there
is it seems to me you could teach in a
history class you could teach about the
historical existence of Jesus and what
was going on in that time without giving
a religious context to it but should but
you once you start doing that then you
open up a can of worms where everyone
wants to bring all the the miracles and
all that stuff in it so where do you
fall in terms of what we can teach
without teaching a myth there's no
viable evidence that Jesus actually
wrote a book about the historical yeah
yeah please take away their stories
there's you know corroborating like
tales and myths and and and maybe non
myths we don't know but there's no
there's no actual evidence that there
was a historical figure named Jesus the
way that there's evidence of historical
figures who you know wrote things or
where we have you know their bones
someplace like that that doesn't exist
for it for Jesus Christ so so and I'm
not saying I don't think Jesus Christ
existed I have no [ __ ] idea but I
don't think that it was empirical I want
to hear evidence and there's absolutely
nothing wrong with talking about the
history of religion or the history of
philosophy in those types of courses I
don't know if like Jesus's existence
should be taught in a history class
because I don't think we should be
making so is that is that the
distinction that should be taught if you
were going to teach you in high school
for example it shouldn't be taught in
social studies but it could be taught in
in a philosophy yeah there's philosophy
there's electives you can choose to take
religion you can have Bible study
classes outside of the high school I
mean you can't just sit there and say
that I know Jesus was historical so I'm
going to teach it but you can't teach
the effects that religion had on history
I mean it's important and you can't
really avoid it yeah I mean that's going
to be part of your history
regardless if you're learning about kind
of American history or if you're
learning about world history like you
can't avoid a conversation about
religion but I think religion as an
institution and it's sociological
affects it's a very different
conversation than the lore and the dogma
within a religion being taught as fact
like that that's where I start so the
church actually existing and having
political you know machinations and
things like that that's real the walk on
water stuff we're all agree it's that
part of my history but no we're
definitely nowhere near science all
right there you go I think we sum that
one up pretty well